hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast
chemometric methods for analysis of 2d
proton carbon methyl NMR spectra of
monoclonal antibodies for higher order
structure characterization presented by
dr. Luke Arbogast a research chemist in
macro molecular structure and function
group at National Institute of Standards
and Technology
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots
bobrucz is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I want to remind
everyone but this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appear on the
screen our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on the ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining your credits
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter dr. Luke Arbogast I will now
turn the presentation over to him
welcome sir all right well thank you for
that introduction I'd like to tell you
about some of the work we're doing at
NIST to develop methods to characterize
the structure of monoclonal antibodies
by NMR you might be wondering why this
has any kind of interest in monoclonal
antibodies well turns out the NIST
mission is to promote us innovation and
industrial competitiveness for
measurement science standards and
technology and one of the most vital
industries in the country right now is
by a pharmaceutical industry so to kind
of demonstrate that we can take a look
at the top 10 drugs by sales in 2017
well we see
is that seven of the ten drugs
highlighted in red are biotherapeutics
and of those seven six of them are
monoclonal antibodies or IgG base drugs
now those seven drugs account for over
sixty billion in sales or roughly the
GDP of Idaho this is tremendously big
business and important business for the
health nation now if we further consider
the antibody market as a function of
time what we see here shown in the blue
diamonds is the total number of
antibodies on the market year-over-year
we see a you know a steady and rapid
increase in the number of antibodies
coming on market in the last thirty
years now in the US these drugs have a
period of exclusivity of twelve years
before their patents expire which time a
generic version is eligible to come to
market by so if we look at the the
figure shown in red those are the labs
coming off patent and if we zoom in
around 2018 we see there's already
twenty or so whose patents have expired
in the coming years they'll be a few
more dozen coming off so I'll leave it
to you the viewer to determine if we're
standing on the precipice of the cliff
or we've gone squarely over the patent
cliff but in the coming years there'll
be a number of a biosimilar Manimal
antibodies that can come to market now
unlike small molecule drugs which are
produced through well-established
chemical procedures and which can be
defined by well-established analytical
procedures biotherapeutics are produced
in living cell tissue and are a
heterogeneous population of closely
related products even from an originator
company in batch batch production will
have heterogeneity in those batches and
therefore is all but impossible for a
biosimilar applicant to perfectly match
the originators product characteristics
therefore there will always be a
risk to the the clinical population or
with the biosimilar drugs the FDA
requires some amount of clinical trials
for that bias no more generic version of
the antibody now in order to be able to
bring those generic biosimilars to
market more rapidly and a lower cost to
the patient
the FDA has told the industry that the
more analytical evidence they can bring
to bear showing similarity of their
products the originator molecule the
less amount of clinical and non-clinical
work that they will be required to
submit thus allowing that drug to come
to market more rapidly and a lower cost
to patients so there's a real need for
better analytical methods to study these
protein therapeutics now there are a
number of product quality attributes
they need to be assayed during this
analytical phase but one of the most
important is the structure of the
protein itself because as we know a
protein structure begets function so if
you don't have the correct structure
safety and efficacy of that potential
drug will be compromised a protein
structure is not just one thing it's
really broken into four distinct
elements starting with the primary
structure or sequence of amino acids
then there's the secondary structure our
local fold or peripheral elements such
as alpha heels alpha helices then beta
strands how those secondary structure
elements fold into a three-dimensional
structures from the tertiary structure
and then the non covalent interactions
of between various proteins form either
functional complexes or aggregates is
termed the quaternary structure together
the secondary through quaternary
structure is the higher order structure
now as you move higher up in structure
they number in type of interactions
become more complex in thus those
structural elements become harder to
measure ironically we use the most
advanced methods for primary structure
namely state of line mass spectrometer
present for secondary tertiary and
quaternary structure we use much more
primitive methods at this
namely FTIR shown on the left and
circular dichroism here shown in middle
these methods are good methods in
general they are high sensitive methods
meaning they can deliver a read on
structure relatively rapidly and from
limited sample quantity but they're all
they're low resolution both
spectroscopically and structurally and
this means that there is potential that
minor differences in structure will be
will that be the methods won't be
sensitive to and if there are if there
are differences seen in these different
spectra there's no direct way to
correlate what those differences mean in
terms of the structure so we think
there's a real room for development of a
better more high-resolution methods to
characterize the structure of these
therapeutic products then thinking about
ways to characterize the structure of
proteins in solution one of the best
ways that comes to mind is nuclear
magnetic resonance so NMR is is a really
a multi-modal tool that we can use for
our structure characterization of these
products is really also an all-in-one
method which means it's sensitive from
the primary route binary structure is
able to directly assess the materials as
per fine
this means it's a label-free method we
simply put the protein in our
spectrometer and we can acquire a data
that that directly relates the structure
now we can do this in one of two
different modes we can do this in a
simple 1d proton mode which provides a
high sensitivity global snapshot of the
protein we everything going on the
protein as similar to the method shown
in the previous slide like you can add
CPR we can also acquire 2d proton
heteronuclear correlation spectra which
well lower in sensitivity provide a high
resolution site-specific information
which really allow us to characterize
the structure of these materials with
much more rigor in current methods the
design rate is a little further we've
been looking at two different 2d NMR
spectra in these
proton nitrogen correlation spectra they
correlate the a mid proton chemical
shift to a chemical shift of the
directly bonded and nitrogen doing
therefore you get a signal or each non
curling amino acid in the protein so on
the Left we have the specter of an
unfolded sample of the small protein
therapeutic g-csf or Foe costume what we
see is that the signal is all coalesced
in the center of the region and we don't
get much dispersion of our signal or
like many characteristic shifts however
when the protein adopts its native
conformation we get this well dispersed
well resolved spectrum which is
characteristic of that specific holder
state of the protein meaning as there is
any change to that structure we would
see shifts in the peak positions as well
as intensity and their shapes so
demonstrate this we can consider in the
small protein phil cross tomb when we
have shown on the left is an overlay of
the drug material bought from a pharmacy
and then overlaid on top in green is an
N 15 labeled sample that we produced
in-house boy see if over all that the
all the peaks may have written on top of
each other but if we do a little closer
we can find that for our in-house
produce material several the peaks have
small little satellite peaks adjacent to
them this lets us know that there's a
minor population in that sample that has
some structural perturbation relative
conformation now we can use isotopically
enriched materials in a battery of other
NMR experiments to assign each of those
Peaks to its constituent amino acid
unless we've done that when we see
changes in our NMR spectra such as what
I'm showing here you can identify which
residues in the protein they belong to
and that allow us to to better detail
what is happening in this case we see
four different is highlighted there
Barnes in name sequence space but when
we plot them when we highlight them on
the structure which we've shown on the
right red we see that they're close in
space indeed there's a tryptophan
residue that's sandwiched in between
them now it turns out in this case a
small amount of my finding oxidation
occurred in our in-house labeled
material that were that in turn led to a
slight change in the conformation of
that tryptophan sidechain and the
aromatic ring current shifted causing a
shift in the chemical shift residues now
this kind of method has has been worked
out and extensively by our colleagues in
the lab of evil by Health Canada and
works great on a protein like filgrastim
but again we're more interested in
monoclonal antibodies so in order to to
really see how we this type of
methodology would work on anybody it's
important that we have a good material
to test our methods in to that in the
last five years or so NIST has been
working on developing an antibody
reference material which we recently
released a few years ago as the NIST map
this map is humanized igg1 Kappa Michael
antibody expressed in meereen cell
culture in a manner similar to how a bio
therapeutic antibody would be produced
this as well as collaborators in
academia industry have extensively
characterises material and publishes the
results of that characterization as
three bone volume monographs with ACS so
this is an excellent material that we
can use now to develop these NMR methods
for a class the class of molecules like
antibodies like I said previously and
these 2d NMR methods work well on a
protein like filgrastim which is around
20 kill Dalton's
but a solution in Tamar has a real
sensitivity to molecular weight so as we
go from something like 20 people killed
on foie gras zooming out to 150
Ilhabela antibody we experience a large
loss in sensitivity of our of our NMR
signal this is because as molecules get
lower
they tumble more slowly in solution and
that leads to more efficient relaxation
of our NMR signals so if we are an
academic lab studying the structure of
an antibody we might do something like
Purdue turi
all the non labile proton sites in the
molecule thereby improving our
relaxation properties over in this
context we must characterize the
materials as they're produced to put
into patients and that means entirely a
natural abundance so we can't anything
like Purdue terrain so we'll have to
consider other ways in which we can
improve the relaxation properties those
unibody now one thing we can do is take
advantage of the thermal stability of
the lab and we can take the temperature
up from around 25 degrees to 50 degrees
which will roughly improve our
relaxation properties by a factor of two
even still as we're showing here on the
right when we put this in our 900
megahertz spectrometer
enquirer over to almost two and a half
days we can see while we do get good
signal it's still quite overlapped and
there's a number of Peaks missing and
then this spectra really isn't adequate
for early for the characterization
methods that we would like to give to
the industry so we can take advantage of
some other well-established biochemistry
family we can enzymatically digest the
antibody into its constituent domains FC
and fab domains which are 50 killed
Alton's and then we can greatly improve
the the relaxation properties perhaps a
bigger improvement we can do is switch
from the proton nitrogen correlation
experiment to a proton carbon methyl
correlation experiment this has a number
of advantages first of all for an animal
properties carbon 13 is almost three
times more abundant than nitrogen 15 so
that's an immediate improvement in our
sensitivity moreover there's rapid relax
a rotation of the methyl group around
its symmetry axis which really serves to
mitigate the effects of slow milk or
tumbling
these large proteins in solution
furthermore you know we're really
looking at a subset of six of the
possible 20 amino acids what we see is
there will distributed throughout the
core of the antibody shown here on the
left so we really get very good
structural coverage even though we're
only looking at roughly a third of the
total antibodies possible moreover it's
these methyl methyl interactions which
are really are responsible for the
energetics that drive and maintain the
folded state protein so we really expect
they'll be quite sensitive to higher
order structure so indeed we can acquire
a very high sensitivity and
high-resolution spectrum of our intact
antibody so here we collect it at our
900 megahertz spectrometer using a
cut-off of signal noise of ten to one we
can identify 210 out of the 221 expected
methyl cross Peaks the rest we surmise
or losing to overlap in the center of
the spectrum so that's greater than 95%
of our expected signals and naturally
that clicking he's a natural abundance
and high resolution high field
spectrometer again showing here on the
left we can we can do this at 900
megahertz and in roughly four or so
hours of course our collaborators and
industry also tell us they don't have
access to that kind of I feel
spectrometer but they do have access to
something around 600 megahertz well you
can do this at 600 megahertz as well
it'll take a little longer not too much
hours or six hours again we can also
digest the antibody into its constituent
domain and because of the improved
relaxation properties of the domains
relatively intact material we can
acquire those spectra and even shorter
times to hours that not hindered three
hours 600 now because we can include
spectra of both the intact antibody and
the the main spectra we can overlay
those those two spectra on top of one
another and compare though it's phil
here on the right and what we find is
overall there is no significant shifts
in peak positions when looking at the
digested material versus the intact
material
in this tells us that the domains do
indeed maintain their structure
even after cleavage and that's important
we don't what I wouldn't want alter the
structure of the domains that would not
be a viable strategy so we can
definitely you know collect data on
these antibodies are intact or is as
fragments and we do this in reasonable
amount of time ultimately we need a way
to to analyze them in terms of structure
and structural comparability now
additionally this would be done by a
trained analyst would look at a
collection of spectra perhaps overlays
I'm like I've done here on the right
look for chef's peak shifts changes and
peak intensities changes in shapes
might identify we might identify certain
peaks and measure their peak properties
but overall this would be somewhat
subjective process based on the you know
the input of the analyst and when you're
doing with a number a large collective
spectrum this can be quite tedious
process for the angles so we really like
to consider a more robust and objective
measures for analyzing so we can do that
by taking our 2d spectra in overlaying a
grid like on top of it like I've shown
here on the upper left morality the grid
we would overlay would be much finer
grid than what I'm showing here of
clarity but what we do is with that grid
we at each intersecting point in the
grid who would take the intensity in the
spectrum then we could take each
intensity as a strip along the indirect
carbon dimension an arrangement intend
to create a vector a spectral intensity
which I'm showing up right then what's
going to be visualized as that pseudo 1d
pop once we have a spectra in this
vector form we can do any number of
statistical analysis on the vector or
collection of vectors so what I'm
showing here on the bottom left is just
another simplest things we can do which
is a direct point-to-point linear
correlation between now in order to test
our methods we need
a good system that has known structural
variation though in order to do that
again we'll take an advantage of some
well-established biochemistry our miss
mAb is produced in mammalian cell
culture and therefore is glycosylated in
SD domain the glycated ligands that are
attached to come in three and three
primary flavors I showed on the left
hand schematic diagram then we turn u 0f
g 1f g 2f and which differ based on the
amount of terminal act oscillation of
those like in Modi's now we can reactor
this map of one of two enzymes either
beta one four o'clock societies will
clip off those terminal at lactose
residues in West primarily the g0f click
o deform alternatively we can react it
with the enzyme pngs F which will cleave
off the glycan entirely and in doing so
will you take the asparagine to 97 to
aspartate so we have again two different
ways we can change them the molecule one
is a very subtle way where we we
slightly change the glycan composition
of the protein without affecting the
protein itself and the second way is a
rather large change where we both
removed like in and mutate the protein
in process alright to confirm the
identity of different species we
performed intact mass spectrometry on
each of them so shown on the left is the
mass spectrum of the nativeness bab
contains a number of different glyco
forms as we can see and it is enriched
in the g 1f form after treatment with a
2:1 for galactosidase we see the
distribution is shifted towards the g0f
form it's important to notice in it that
in this sample which we've which we've
termed EXO gal miss bab all the glycans
microforms president are also present in
the native form it's just the relative
populations have been shifted
alternatively when we have the PNG ASF
treated
as man or deed glycosylated we see we
have omen nearly homogeneous population
of that eke like oscillated form so
again we have a very modest change in
the XFL this map a much larger change in
the eagle-eyed this man to further
confirm that then didn't have any major
changes during the reaction we performed
capillary electrophoresis assay to look
for disulfide degradation the XO gal
this map which is shown on top we see
very low levels of those testified
detergent products that are in line with
the negative one for the big line is NAB
shown on the bottom see a slightly
larger percentage of the disulfide
evidence but there's still quite minor
we all burn I think this is a problem
though because again the XO a gal miss
tab which is supposed to be our very
modest difference doesn't exhibit quite
a large discrepancy relative the
nativeness bab or as d by in this map
it's supposed to be substantially
different from the nist map so we don't
mind that there's a slight increase in
those bisulfite difference so after
verifying the identity and integrity of
the samples we performed our 2e proton
call carbon methyl no more experiments
on all the samples so i've shown here on
the left is an overlay of nativeness
navy blue with the big line is matte red
and what we see is that overall the two
special look quite similar but there are
a number of peak shifts and loss of peak
intensities in the t minus ab form and
when we perform the direct linear
point-to-point correlation what we see
is some loss in correlation and some
discrepancies which leads a lower
Pearson's correlation on the other hand
when we look at the nativeness map
versus the X of Y on this map all we see
is that they are overlay shows almost no
difference to the I than when we perform
a point-to-point correlation you get a
very strong correlation which is nearly
unity when factoring in experimental
sequence so we can I easily detect a
difference between these samples using
this now we know there are differences
so we'd really like to consider more
rigorous methods for to analyzing
spectra to get at those differences and
in order to think about how we might do
this it's useful to think about how
different ways we can represent the
spectrum so of course if you have a
collection of spectrum you can simply
maintain the mass spectra and as a
spectral library and as I've shown
previously you could similarly convert
these spectra into special intensity
vectors and then have a matrix of
spectral intensity vectors but a
spectral intensity vector is really
equivalent to a point in a spectral
intensity space which I'm showing here
on the right now this is shown as a
three-dimensional space for convenience
but to really if we had an n-dimensional
spectral intensity vector this would be
a point in a high-end dimensional space
so if we were to plot all these spectra
in this high-end dimensional space what
we would find is they would all
basically lay right on top of each other
including those di spectra and this is
there's there's good reason for this so
if we look at the di versus Innis map
spectra again what we see is that most
of the spectra is actually empty door
noise the part of the spectrum that
contains signal the vast majority of it
is actually identical between the
species and is really only a handful a
couple hundred points out of a couple a
hundred thousand points that vary
between these two spectra so we're
really looking for a needle in a
haystack just some degree so we'd like
to do is just really get rid of the
haystack like compress this high
dimensional hundred thousand dimensional
space down into a few dimensions were of
maximum variance and when I'm describing
this principle
opponent Alice so when we do PCA our
collection of spectra what we can see
now is it both 600 or 900 megahertz we
get very good separation of our D gly
EXO gal and native populations now each
of these populations of spectra or
collected uniform acquisition parameters
except for the number of signal scans
for signal averaging meaning that across
each cluster there's a variety of
spectra with different signal or noise
ratios so highlighted here is a table of
those signalers ratios and and what I
really want to draw attention to the
highlighted columns would show the
maximum and minimum signal noise for
each of those clusters and we can see
that you know they vary by as much as
two to three times the highest of the
lowest no it's really incredible is for
those low signal noise spectra or
collected with just sixteen scans in
just about an hour experimental time but
they still cluster quite well with the
high signal-to-noise spectra collected
with as much as one hundred twenty eight
days and eight hours and this is because
PCA will tend to take the random
variation from experimental noise and
spread it across higher order principal
components and leave the lower order
prints components of most interest in
sensitive to that noise and always
sensitive spectral varies that we really
care now because we were able to get
such good separation of EXO now in
native mismatched species we wondered
that just at how sensitive the PCA
method might be to small variation in
order to get out that took our Excel gal
species and then began blending back in
increasing amounts of native this map
and then performed PCA on the resulting
spectrum so we see here is our PC a
loading plot for a variety of our xov
I'll miss map when it's
let me see down to as low as 15 percent
London xov I'll witness NAB we still get
very good separation between it and 100%
native population going below 15% down
to 7.5% we still see some visual
separation of the clusters
however our 95% confidence intervals for
those clusters begin to overlap and we
can no longer statistically discriminate
them however if we were to take a 2
Sigma interval which is shown with the
red dashed lines we do see we can still
get separation but that suggests if that
we were to collect more spectra we could
perhaps indeed statistically
differentiate this picture still
conservatively for this this application
we estimate that PCA is able to
discriminate as little as a 10% change
in that Glinka composition as determined
from the exit valve versus native
began we want to point out the extra
Vilnius map and nativeness had spectra
are identical to the I if we were to do
a similar experiment where we blended
the divinest map with the native this
we'd expect that limit of detection
would be much lower than 10% still I
began talking about NMR by discussing
how we really want to use it because of
its ability to provide high resolution
structural information and once we've
reduced it and the spectra are down to
their loadings and a principal component
space we've lost at high resolution
information however when you do the pca
you not only produce the special loading
plots proxies you also produce special
loading vectors which are linear
combinations of the spectra in the
library which describe the sources of
variation as phone and we can take those
special loading vectors
Noorie capitulate the missed extra and
then overlay them on a reference
spectrum as I'm showing here on the Left
we have the loading spectrum a blue and
red
or the EXO calmest man overlaid the
reference spectrum from the name of mr.
gray and we can see a number of Peaks
that that are a change with respect to
the miss tab in this analysis now we're
currently working on assigning all the
different peaks in the spectrum so I
can't show you specific residues that
are that change as a function of the
glycan remodeling however we do know
that in the bottom left-hand side of the
spectrum the residues which are circled
along the an acetyl glucosamine of the
SC attached to I can now it's somewhat
obvious that if we were to alter the
glycan by removing from OBE lactose
residues or cleave the glad I can't off
entirely don't those signals would
change still I think it illustrates how
we can use this type of analysis to well
attach some very small changes in
structure in a Marc spectra and then we
can map those changes in spectra back to
structure with high resolution now
alternatively we could overlay these
principal loading spectra onto the
engine to special from individual
domains so that's what I've done here in
this case we have a loading spectra from
the éxito bail system an overlaid on top
of the levy this map FC domain spectrum
now probably not surprising that we've
moved the altered the FC attached glycan
and all the variation we're saying
indeed is contained within the SD domain
but again this can illustrate how we can
use this PCA to both attack differences
and map those differences at destruction
I'd like to end with one last case study
which may be a little more realistic
application for industry and we've done
here is looked at the constant
concentration dependence
so on the left we have the total
spectral intensity of a proton series of
proton 1d spectra as a function of NIST
map concentration at various
temperatures and what we see is that as
we increase the concentration from 10
Meg's per ml up to 45 X per mole we see
a monotonic increase in our spiritual
signal intensity once we cross over 45
mins per mil though we see a mark change
in the slope of with respect to
concentration and this tells us that
there's likely a some sort of change in
the hydrogen name of properties between
those two different regimes so we then
went in and recorded our 2d proton
carbon methyl spectra as a function of
concentration this time only at 323
Kelvin that's then afterwards we
performed the PCA on the spectrum which
is shown here on the right and what we
see again is actually a very similar
distribution the function of
concentration in our principal ownit
space where we see a marked change in
the distribution at 45 minutes ago now
it be a lot of work you know to record a
series of TV spectra only to
recapitulate the results that were
obtained by requiring that 1d spectrum
again the pca provides not only this
looting plot that it also provides us
spectral loading vectors which we can
map back to structure so again here's
what we see here is the loadings for the
second principal component for the
concentration series mapped back on to
the is map reference spectrum in gray we
see a number of residues that are
changing again because we know we know
which we have the individual domain
spectra we know which peaks belong to
which domain we can we can figure out
very readily
which domains are being affected by the
concentration change so here in blue we
can yeah the number of residues from the
fab domain which are changing with
respect to concentration
but there is a far greater number of
residues SD domain that changes the
function of conservation it's really
just an inclusion that there's some sort
of interaction between FC domains that
as you go to higher and higher
concentration because there's an
increase in viscosity of the solution
and thus the change in the hydrodynamic
properties now once we finished
assigning in this spectrum we'll be able
to identify the residues specifically
and develop a more in-depth molecular
model for this interaction so with that
I will conclude just hopefully point out
that that high resolution a 2d proton
carbon methyl NMR is possible on natural
abundant protein therapeutics including
monoclonal antibodies that the reloading
spectra are suitable for characterizing
the major controversies of these
biotherapeutics in solution that the
spectra can be collected in our to a few
hours making them really competitive
with traditional lower resolution
virtual characterization techniques and
finally that these spectra can be used
this really discriminate social
variation with very low levels of
detection and can identify the sources
of structural variation that's residue
level residues and with that like to
acknowledge the team here in NIST our
group leader John Marino my colleague
Robert Benson and in vertigo or my
colleague Frank Doyle who was
instrumental in implementing the PCA on
the spectrum work is all supported by
the NIST by manufacturing initiative and
was performed at the WM Keck Center for
circle biology that seems to do for
bioscience and biotechnology research in
Rockville thank you for your attention
and thank you dr. Arbogast for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of our webinar
well address the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
and drop-down box located on the far
left of your presentation window type
the question into the box that appear on
the screen and click the send button our
speaker will follow up with you via
email so let's take a look at some of
our viewers questions dr. Arbogast you
demonstrate the 2d NMR methods on the
NIST
monob but how generally applicable is
the method to pharmaceutical labs yeah
that's a great question so obviously we
love the NIST map here in this we spend
a lot time developing in and it's a
great material for message development
but of course you know it's it is maybe
not as challenging as some of the
real-world molecules out there being
used by industry we've we have here NIST
analyzed a few other labs using this
method and we were they've generally
been successful however our colleagues
at Health Canada recently published a
paper in the journal of pharmaceutical
and biomedical analysis where they
bought several I think six ABS off the
market and repeated this kind of
methodology and didn't show that at
least that you could collect the to be
methyl spectra on those those clinically
relevant maps now I mean I would just
point out again that every every mAb it
is a unique case so some some labs may
be a little more difficult to do this on
than others but in general we do think
this is applicable to IgG one class of
NAB's
in general thank you for that answer dr.
Arbogast your spectra are all acquired
at 50 degrees this C is high for many
proteins will this be a problem for
application to other Maps right so
the NIST lab has an initial melting
transition of its SD domain around 62
degrees so you know we can safely go to
50 degrees with this material I think a
lot of you know a lot of maps will have
a similar melting transition for their
fcg around that time at that temperature
I mean you could take safely take them
to 50 degrees that that's not going to
be universally true but we can't I can't
tell you that we do perform we do
collect the spectra routinely at 37
degrees or even 25 degrees you know it
it takes a little longer because the
sensitivity is a little lower but it is
doable and at 37 degrees really you
don't actually notice that much of a
drop-off in your spectral quality so
this message you know can be done at
lower temperatures if thank you for that
question from a viewer is PCA needs to
be a naive approach
pinellas analyzing spectra would
supervise approaches make more sense
right so I mean this will kind of be you
know context dependent so it for first
Bess's like biosimilar comparison to an
originator molecule I really you know I
think naive approach is probably where
you want be you don't want to assume
anything about your system you really
just want to say is this spectra from
you know the biosimilar the same as the
spectra from the originator and if they
are then the structure of those two
molecules is essentially again Wow we
can think of more specific cases in you
know for for product testing say a
particular manufacturers as the problem
with oxidation of a specific residue and
that's that's what they're really
interested in and they really want to
know about that more specifically well
if they know what residues being
oxidized and they know what residues are
in the vicinity of that oxidation then
then using a method where
that that information is in fluent and
those those specific Peaks are looked at
more intensely than the rest of the
spectrum that might make more sense so
whether you do a naive our supervised
approach will depend on the context and
you know I think both are are acceptable
you know and can be justified right now
we haven't really looked so much at
supervised methods but that is sort of
an area we're hoping thank you dr.
Arbogast would you like to provide some
closing remarks to our good viewers
today oh I just hope that I've been able
to show you the power of what we can do
with NMR and the biocera feed experience
and if you give you a flavour or some of
the things we do here at NIST beyond you
know keeping the time standard been
telling you a kilogram is kilograms
that's what I have dr. Arbogast thank
you again for your presentation and your
important research I'd also like to
thank
labret for making today's educational
webcast possible before I go and I
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January 2019 you'll receive an
email from lab regime the webcast will
be available for replay please share
this announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that's
all for now and thank you for joining us
we hope to see you again soon bye bye